du mobilier des tableaux équestres cette
esquisse d'eugène delacroix des dizaines
d'oeuvres fruit de la collection privée
du propriétaire du château partent à la
fin du mois en vente chez christie's
et ce week-end les clients se pressent
pour les derniers repérages comme
jean-françois paul tôt intéressé par un
ensemble de sièges néoclassique
ils sont vraiment parfaits très passe
partout on est très bien ainsi
c'est toujours et là c'est la bonne
hauteur
on est très confortable malgré que ce
soit pas capitonné voilà c'est ce
qu'aime des gens aujourd'hui ça fait
partie des importantes que j'ai pu gérer
dans mon métier parce que plus de milo
avec des affreux même très importante
que ce soit dans l'art graphique dans le
mobilier les objets d'art c'est une
réunion très importante
la vente de ces mille au résultat de
trente ans de collection doit permettre
à son propriétaire jean louis remilleux
de poursuivre la restauration du château
entamé il ya trois ans d'iguane méritait
sérieusement d'être restaurée d'être
repris d'être de revivre d'être
ressuscité parmi les bâtiments à
restaurer les écuries mais aussi un
exceptionnel théâtre privé symbole de la
vie à la française
voilà précisément le bâtiment qui abrite
le théâtre
alors ce petit théâtre a été créés au
19e siècle en 1830 1840 par la famille
de chabrits lens est un petit théâtre de
société mais il est dans une dépendance
qui donne de sérieux signes de faiblesse
des pierres brisé des assises bancal et
un toit qui menace de s'effondrer dans
ce petit théâtre de 100 places
sarah bernardt ou encore offenbach ont
joué une fois la restauration terminé
d'ici un an
jean-louis remilleux souhaite faire
venir des comédiens pour des lectures et
des musiciens pour des concerts sur les
dizaines d'hectares de parc qui entoure
le château